your head wind welcome to the city of
gentian share hollow from Argentina to
be get Kings Indian would like a
convenient again that worked beautifully
last couple of games know what is that
okay if I if I played d5 you might and
my flavor should take so I rather go
into amarok see unless you place yes
something like that luxury ever take
this is probably some kind of theory and
I know I just I just prevent this Bishop
move and develop next
yeah queen bee six would fit into the
night 64 scenario but I'm just not doing
it I will just fly developing move check
okay so quit you one yeah I can come
back I don't want to allow it p straight
yeah I was just thinking that this might
be possible because takes bishop take
the temple that's okay i don't have to
take
from a structural point of view one leg
did is pretty bad so he has to justify
it with with activity this could be an
idea relay absolutely I'm so I can you
two need to stop f3 until I Queen d2
threatens on f4 and I can take it seven
so may I'd look a little bit or together
King side but okay I don't see something
special anything special anything
special I strongly right if it covers
that this year like look at 7i play
Queen d2 and then I'm really have for
age six I take and just take is seven
and then drop the bishop bag f2h for tf2
since seems to be good for wine against
this guy ever twelve score of 12 to
three with not a single draw that's it's
funny not one draw yeah she takes such a
long time on I might as well get some
fresh water
so he's giving me the spawn to go back
this is not a totally clear thing I mean
he has some compensation with the night
think i'm gonna go back so i want to be
quick em how to do that this end could
be one or something this is a temple
somewhat somewhat okay i don't want to
take
one life no cannot get rid of the noise
easily yes Bishop d3 also was an
interesting idea
[Music]
okay yeah this is seven not easy at all
Bishop f110 I want to try with rook f1
to expel the Queen I wonder if you can
actually take that already I'm not sure
you look strange to be honest yes you
need you need the bishop for the
sacrifices on each three well now now i
get an ending okay i understand that my
bishop is not a good piece but i have to
have the default okay if i trade myself
I wonder if h4 is an idea cheeks and
then f4 night f4 is extremely annoying
how do you have to go with my gut
instinct and play it didn't think about
that move unfortunately okay so
[Music]
Jacob ship f3 I don't get to the d6 porn
is the problem he gets down
and night f2 time morning check I didn't
think about my Kenya oh oh my goodness
my king is in trouble okay and no I
cannot take h one such a [ __ ] I wanted
to take H for which is not possible ah
and you know yes yes the kriging 93 now
ah or this one even on a bad game check
check my mind why these games they
really really kostner of him okay
you would like have some congestion here
for sure alysha base sequence on come on
it bad don't believe in that come on I
just have to be just played as well and
then black should of course should never
win yeah i'm not saying why should win
but losing is really something that
should not happen I probably shouldn't
take you now thats to what the engine is
giving their just King be one Queen f2
because that gets stuck there and you
cannot go g4 and I can just improve my
position at will and this gives him this
Knight to f4 idea this is what prompted
me to play this and TNA I'll just play
at five I mean I just played this
extremely bad check the Overlook tons of
stuff sack I was thinking that yeah if I
can take on h4 which is a conclusion of
the nation was just a terribly played
[Music]
yeah especially dueling I mean drawing
would be okay somewhat refusing the game
after reaching this position it's pretty
bad yet it's just better to play like
this let's say because he doesn't have
any idea in this position g4 I just take
twice and I can't fly kingi one rupee
one and try to do stuff slowly it's
probably a draw because well then my
bishop is bad but and losing who
shouldn't happen losing should happen ok
anyway thanks for watching